Bellingham Washington May 2004 detective
al Jensen is in the middle of building a
federal case against George waggers the
president of the Bandidos the Bandidos
are one of the largest outlaw motorcycle
gangs in the world he's determined to
prove that waggers is the boss of a
nationwide crime syndicate
Jensen set up a wire room in a secret
location somewhere on the edge of town
he listens to every call made into and
out of weygers house these are the
actual recordings that's national
business he got the port here he's gonna
get the goddamn point again what are you
doing
but mostly he listens to waggers and his
friends discussing their sex lives just
getting fat as a pig maybe I should have
built the bedroom here into a team I
don't know well I'll be get laid tonight
I think she wants job took well that's
cool that's no exercise yeah but Jensen
isn't laughing if he's successful he'll
bring down the president of America's
largest outlaw motorcycle club the man
he's known his entire career al Jensen
and George weygers live and work in
Bellingham a small blue-collar town 25
miles south of the Canadian border both
men share a lifelong passion for Harley
Davidsons always loved Harley's on its
unique bike al Jensen like 1 million
Americans is a proud member of a
motorcycle club
99% of us are there for the enjoyment of
riding and the camaraderie that goes
with it but a tiny proportion of bikers
live outside the law across America
there are an estimated 10,000 outlaw
bikers also known as one-percenters
there's just one percent of this riding
community that are using this as a
criminal organization and they're
outlaws George waggers is a
one-percenter he's the president of the
only outlaw motorcycle club in America
that rivals the Hells Angels I've always
tried to be a Bandido 24 hours a day
seven days a week no matter where I am
this exclusive footage has never been
seen outside the Bandito motorcycle club
until now
it shows a bandido weekend away in
Washington in 1973 these weekends are
compulsory they're notorious for heavy
drinking drug taking and hard partying
it's clear that the Bandidos relish
their outlaw status their patch is
affixed to swastika flags not that the
Bandidos are necessarily Nazis but they
are out to shock by 2004 waggers has
risen through the ranks and controls
2,400 harley-davidson riding bikers
organized into 90 chapters across the
United States and as far away as
Australia Malaysia and Denmark
even though Jensen and waggers are on
opposite sides of the law
cop and biker have a grudging respect
for each other
George will have unique ways to see each
other in town and if there's Stamper
tree there I go up and say hi to
one time hal called me up to tell me
that another club had a hit out on me
said we don't want you to get killed in
our town i said owl tried to go out of
town and get killed
[Music]